what's the process let's start with
maybe the cure first and that we can go
to the vaccine what's the actual process
that people will go through to test and
actually validate that yes there is
something out there that can be a cure
it's a long process so you have very
early studies and cultures and then next
you have a very small trials of you know
50 patients and then you kind of keep
rolling it up from there the u.s. is
very cautious very regulated when it
comes to studying and approving that
they approving medications and that has
saved the u.s. in the past from certain
medications behind for like the
thalidomide is a chemical is actually
very toxic to pregnant women and so this
was rule about in Europe at the US and
wait hold the brakes on that and that
turned out to make a decision in the
situation of a pandemic though it kind
of works against us because we don't
have six months a year 18 months to be
like we're gonna find a vaccine or
medication to treat this and go through
all those proper steps which we usually
do and so that's where you know I've
kind of been focusing on a treatment
potential treatment that's already
widely available known safety effect
profile and something that about a
million people are so globally are
already on so if this could actually
cure or help reduce the symptoms or
reduce the amount of people get infected
with corona virus that could be huge it
wouldn't really you could expedite those
trials in that process much more quickly
than developing a whole brand new
treatment over the next 6 to 18 months
got it and then is it similar process
for the vaccine as it is for the Cure
or is there a completely different
process with different timelines and
complexities I would say the vaccine
would even probably take a little bit
longer especially if you talk because
now you're talking about willing this
vaccine out to a large number of people
so if you're gonna also start making
like the flu vaccine when you're
recommending just about everyone in
America
in the world gets us vaccine you don't
want to mess that up right
whereas a treatment you can be like okay
well this person's already sick we know
what there is a three percent mortality
rate we know that this treatment has
very favorable side effect profile
potentially and so it's much easier to
prove that as opposed to ruling out
something that's in healthy people that
we don't you know the side effect
profiles was studied less because it's
always that concern with about there's
always that concern with the vaccine
that that weakened virus could mutate
into a harmful virus and then you know
you don't wanna die from a vaccine got
it and I think that I saw this is like
the Imperial College paper that recently
came out their whole thing was even if
you start identifying what you think
could be a vaccine it's got that really
long time frame kind of 12 to 14 months
they said at the earliest until you
could confirm it and it sounds like a
lot of that sort of what you're saying
is revolves around just like you can't
go tell people this can save you from
you know cope in nineteen but oh by the
way there's 20 percent chance could kill
you at the same time right you've got a
for sure you know it's actually safe
right the first three in medicines do no
harm right so you don't want to
introduce into something that's gonna
actually be more info than just you know
maybe moving up the course the disease
got it okay and so talk to us a little
bit about the the potential cures that
that you're looking at I know that there
are some some encouraging I think I
think reports and data that starting to
come out now as to how there may be some
things that will actually cure this or
at least reduce the symptoms yeah so
what I've been focusing on with with one
of my colleagues is basically about it
was about two weeks ago now I started
seeing evidence coming out and
guidelines and from China and South
Korea about chloroquine being a
potential treatment for corona virus and
started doing a little more digging to
that there was some mechanisms of action
that showed how hydroxychloroquine or
hydroxychloroquine they kind of use them
interchangeably they're very similar
drugs I can talk about the differences
in a little bit but it has mechanisms to
decrease viral replication
in cells and actually eliminate that
process entirely at least in vitro and
they studied this in the SARS version of
corona virus and so there's already in
Rita a piece of base of amino studies
for that this kind of idea which wasn't
really talked about yet about Korbin
being and treatment or Korres was kind
of justified in my mind when I started
to see that United Kingdom banned export
of the active pharmaceutical ingredients
in chloroquine China did similar they
essentially announced in early February
look the priority they brought up in
back in the Chinese New Year early and
said hey look we need you to produce
hydrography chloroquine and high-volume
we're gonna stop all exports of this and
we need to prioritize Wuhan in our own
country to make sure that we can stop
this and then in March 9th I had been
contact with pharmacies and one of the
farmers like under contacted the
manufacturer rising Pharma of workmen
and announced and told us there's a
national shortage of it and so all these
things in my mind was like you know
basically triggered there's something
big going on madison's either they think
cork went maybe an effective treatment
or it already potentially is an
effective treatment and so that's when I
started talking about it on Twitter and
a lot of colleagues and this is when one
of my colleague on Twitter contact me I
said hey I've been studying for Qin for
a number of years it looks like and I
know the mechanism of action behind this
very well I have a paper that I put
together take a look at it and see what
you think and I looked at it I changed
added some clinical elements to it I was
actually already familiar with working
on a clinical level because one of the
main side effects is vision loss you can
have is very rare but you can have
vision loss from it and so I've seen a
lot of patients that were on it and so I
was able to add those elements to it and
more of a clinical I guess impression of
it and again this because that was an
ophthalmologist so I saw that's why I
saw those patients and we released that
paper and it got a ton of attention it
was retweeted by Elon Musk
shortly thereafter and just kind of blew
up from there and we were contacted by
the press the media my co-authors are
Greg Logano
now banana war Ingram show he was on
Tucker Carlson last night anything as I
can cleanse back today as well and it's
you know it's really it's starting to
become a little bit more justified so
what we had was this kind of summary of
all this evidence I think the show the
corporate might be ineffective treatment
and then what I announced yesterday
which was remain in contact with Didier
rail this very famous ibex is disease
doctor MD PhD out of France and he's
been studying this for the last few
weeks as a treatment for patients with
corner virus and he had very positive
results as a very it was a small study
just about 36 people that stayed
enrolled till the end but it shoulder
the combination of hydroxychloroquine
plus azithromycin so again i drastic
workman is like cork when it just
actually has a safer side effect profile
so it's kind of used more often than
chloroquine but showed a very small
sample size still but showed a hundred
percent decrease in viral load in in the
hundred percent of the patients receive
both hydroxychloroquine and as a therm
Ison and so this is a small kind of
small sample size but very positive
results regarding this treatment method
and this was announced by my co-author
on tucker carlson last night and it
seems like donald trump reacted to that
as he in his press conference today i
talked about it we talked about
anti-malarial medications
hydroxychloroquine how this needs to be
expedited and cut through the red tape
if possible to allow physicians to make
physicians feel comfortable in using
this drug to treat cove 819 positive
patients